jennifer lopez returned to the stage
with her teenager emmy for the first
time since performing together at the
super bowl halftime show back in 2020
that's right the pair performed a duet
of christina perry's a thousand years
during the los angeles dodgers
foundation blue diamond gala and it was
a very special performance as jlo seemed
to confirm her 14 year old uses gender
neutral pronouns as caught on camera by
a fan in the audience performed together
was in a big stadium like this
and i asked them to sing with me all the
time but they won't so this is a very
special occasion they're very very busy
and booked
and pricey it costs me when they come
out
but they're worth every single penny
because they're my favorite
duet partner of all time
[Music]
so if you would indulge me
help us by putting your lights up
let's light this building up tonight
let's light the building up tonight
[Music]
uh i got my
stuff for working away
and i really like some of these comments
that are coming through about the royal
family m says the only real way to shake
up the royal family is referendum which
i found really fascinating that you said
that heidi says will never happen in a
million years they won't release
anything
i don't know i think that with the
pressure of the public they're going to
have to release it but yes
yeah all right well talking about that
clip we just saw jlo yeah how sweet is
that i know
what are you what are your thoughts that
she did something like that for
i mean for emmy just to have for emmy to
have the support of their mother in that
way is just so powerful and for jlo
one of the biggest stars in the entire
world to support them in that way
and bring them out on stage and and use
the correct pronouns this is where we
talk about the world changing and
evolving
as the royal family needs to evolve
i'm still upset about it
they're way behind but during pride
month how incredible is this jlo is one
of the biggest stars in the world to
bring emmy out there and just show them
all that support
is so powerful just for visibility
around the world because i think there
may be people out there who still don't
understand
certain pronouns and it gives people a
chance to be like hmm let me take notes
up let me take notice let me let me you
know
figure this out and read more and learn
and that's important we always need to
continue to educate ourselves yeah and i
think that's part of it too as parents
and you know we were stuck in our ways
and we're learning our you know learning
the new ways and and i think that's when
we really do need to listen to our our
kids because i'm being educated in a
very powerful way with my kids and i sit
there and i listen and i understand it
and i think that's exactly what jennifer
lopez did here at this moment is that my
child talked to me about this and and
she put it out there and so it's a and
you're right it's the right time to do
it and did you watch your halftime show
special i haven't yet oh okay i can't
talk to you about it okay you need to
watch it because she she does this thing
with her hair and i just wait what is it
show but she did no no
once you watch it call me or text me and
then you'll be like oh that's how it's
anyways it's it's a great it's a great
thing to watch and just to see her
perspective of everything she's gone
through with ben affleck and her life
and the way she was put out there and
what this halftime show actually meant
to her so you know jennifer lopez is one
of a kind like she
when you think of hustle and hard work
you think of her she's been around
forever and she's she has her foot in
yeah every part of the business and
she's not one of those people who just
does it and doesn't do it
great yeah no matter what j.lo is doing
she puts herself into it and she means
business she means business and i love
that about her i really really do yeah i
love this favorite jennifer lopez movie
i want to know yeah
oh my gosh everything uh but i have to
say the the one with um
oh my gosh
the monster-in-law mama oh
monster-in-law
the cell was really good yes
anaconda i love anaconda have you ever
seen anaconda no oh you need to watch it
it's a classic
she's an article she's an anaconda she
is it's her
she's the main woman in it mind blown
and also selena
yeah
iconic iconic for sure yeah
iconic okay any comments there i can't
you know she's making a difference just
like madonna back in the day love it i
think that's i think that's a great way
to end that yeah it's pretty amazing
what she's doing